in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Darren
and Becky are with us hey guys how are
you good
welcome welcome good to have you so
you're here to do a debt-free scream yes
sir where do you live we live in
Midlothian Texas just south of Dallas no
very fun good to have you guys how much
dad have you paid off we have paid off
five hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in eight years
Wow that is our dream home
that must be the house yeah making what
kind of range of income during that time
about two hundred and fifty Wow what do
you guys do for a living he's an ER
doctor there's always that okay and the
house is paid for completely everything
everything is paid for yes and he's and
everything I love it very cool very well
done
Wow so tell me the story of what
happened eight years ago well we started
about we stumbled on to you 15 years ago
on the radio and knowing that they give
physicians and no financial knowledge
whatsoever
we were headed way down the wrong path
the whole life insurance all that kind
of stuff
found you got out of debt for the first
time except for the house and then we
wanted to build our dream house so we
sold and just kept going there we go and
then plow through the dead on that bird
on air
yep five hundred and fifty thousand
dollars what's the house worth it's
worth about with the property about six
hundred way to go very nice so how's it
feel all these years ago you decide to
go into med school I'm guessing you went
into debt for that yes yeah and you had
to clean that up yes and then you come
out and then you get the house and you
gotta get the house cleaned up and so
all of those years of fighting and
scratching and clawing to become a doc
and then make the doc money but now you
don't have any dad right that's gotta
feel like a huge release yes we first
started listening to you and I mean
paying a monthly bill for my debt just
seemed like the normal thing but then I
realized I'm gonna be 65 when I pay this
stuff off so that's when we started
attacking it and
and we came debt-free very fun very fun
cool so Becky who's idea was this way
back there it was both of ours you know
we heard you and it just made sense and
the biblical foundations were right on
our you know right up our alley and you
know through all of that
the the tithe came off the top of the
cheque and we don't do a lot of charity
but four percent always went to the
church so they could do the charity that
never wavered his in the last year he
actually did a fellowship switching
specialties to palliative and hospice
care which is a lot lower but a lot more
ministry involved yeah the last year I
took about a of my peg what God couldn't
have to do the fellowship but it's it's
something that I wanted to get into
hospice and palliative medicine so on
what is palliative medicine palliative
actually starts before Hospice Care you
can get the treatment when you're still
getting curative therapy we do a lot of
hospital consults okay very cool well
that is a ministry that's an incredible
time to to be around someone so I stuff
well very fun you guys and the kids are
with the ages and names
we've got Zach who's 20 Taylor who is 16
and Jake who was 11 and they've been on
the journey with us from day one all
right I mean Jake was three when we
started Jake was three about when we
started you actually had a different
opening song and when he was two years
old you changed that song and he noticed
immediately that you changed your
opening song that's how much we listened
to you oh that's fun that is very fun
well congratulations you guys I'm very
proud of you when people hear that
you've paid off your debt
they probably automatically say well I'm
Richter fifty thousand I can pay mine
off too but you've really you've really
had to concentrate on this what are the
secrets to getting out of debt the
budget sure yeah the envelopes and the
cash was good and just following
biblical principles I mean we didn't buy
new cars he drove the old beater pickup
for years even when all the other guys
were getting it all yeah you know just
just but yeah he's probably only doctor
with the old beat-up I had the I had the
smoking
because everybody went out sat on my
truck for smoke breaks two minutes
smoked when it was running just sticking
to it just you know stick and stick and
stick into it
yeah steady steady eight years yes now
everything is paid for now you can do
whatever you want to do and we can come
here on spring break and yell we're
debt-free I love it I'm glad you did
alright Darren and Becky and tribe from
the Dallas Texas area five hundred and
fifty thousand dollars paid off that's
house and everything after the med
school debt boom they attack this eight
years making two hundred and fifty a
year count it down let's hear a debt
free scream ready three two one very
proud of you very proud of you well done
well done well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you